where do you think free Community
College actually comes
from tweet me at ask CR I would like to
know where do you think free things come
from when the government is providing
for it do you are unless you know what
maybe it's just because a lot of these
people aren't a
taxpayer was it 40 something percent was
it 43% 47% of Americans 47% of Americans
don't pay federal income tax
nothing at all nothing yeah for you
didn't know that it's just insane I
can't imagine not paying taxes how do
you work in AM radio fund dip and you
have never heard this stat before you
are a Marvel let me tell you how it ends
okay you now have people protesting
tution hikes they're going to the best
school in the country in Mcgill and
they're spending like a few hundred
bucks at the most it might be a couple
thousand a year and they were protesting
hikes of a couple hundred
because they got so used to it being
free well do you know what's happened
with
Mill debt they can't keep good teachers
you are talking dozens of millions of
dollars actually I I don't have the
numbers in front of me because I'm I'm
I'm done re I've been doing the research
on Barack Obama's statements in
community college in the States but
we'll get this up in the video at
louderwithcrowder.com uh last I checked
it was 30 something million do in debt
I'm sure it's quite higher than that now
because that was several years ago that
was many years ago when I still lived in
Canada so your best
university for which students are are
now protesting that they might actually
have to pay money is 30 something
million do in debt let's call it $50
million in debt now let's just give it a
nice rounded number what do you think
that does to an education system you
think education gets better or worse
let's just use simple economics will
education get better or
worse worse if you don't have any money
go ding ding ding ding ding lesser man
answer and the problem is once people
get used to the free crap that they
don't deserve no one deserves free
School uh okay I actually have this
number right here from my my lovely
friend here uh McGill resident system
$79 million in
debt free school for two years $79
million in debt in Canada same thing
with doctors they same thing with their
health their healthare it's subsidized
Healthcare what happens all of the good
doctors leave
because it gets harder and harder to
find jobs they're not being paid well
enough things nothing is
free these things don't come to you for
free it's not free Community College
it's taxpayer funded taxpayer subsidized
Community College and guess what you're
going to have to burden the taxpayers
more and more and more and considering
that many kids who are going to school
are not becoming taxpayers because
they're gutless Mor On's getting a
doctorate in
philosophy I don't know if we're going
to recoup our
investment we'll talk about this more
after the break and why I'm angry at the
world and have contempt for my
generation who demand free school you
don't deserve free school you don't
deserve it get if you deserve free
school you'd have a scholarship
dummy you stupid goofy dumb person get
on a swim team smoke some pot go Phelps
increase your performance get a
scholarship athletically I don't care
just don't demand that I pay for your
tuition doesn't come from a ma magical
land of chocolate Rivers
okay